[Music]
today's question comes from robert in
alabama i'm a couple of years into a
middle management position in a tech
field at a fortune 100 company i dislike
the politics and endless meanings of
management and miss being able to work
on solving technical issues my salary
didn't change much
when i moved into this new role how do i
talk to my bosses about stepping back
into my non-management position and is
this even a good idea it happens a lot
all the time and first of all it is a
good idea that you realize hey
i don't want to be in a leadership role
i want to solve technical problems
that's really key uh so then it's just a
function of being clear sitting down
with your leaders and going hey uh i'm
grateful for this opportunity to be
promoted uh here's the deal uh it's not
for me i'm not cut out for it it's not
you guys it's me uh it's not my jam what
i do love more than anything and i now
realize it is just being in the trenches
getting my hands dirty solving technical
problems but i know that i took this is
there a way that we can smoothly move me
back into that role
i'd be grateful i think that's your
approach it's about posture and it's
about just owning the fact that hey uh
you took a promotion which is the normal
human thing to do but it's not the best
fit for you yeah and the weird thing is
you might actually make more money as a
maker that's exactly right people that
are in the make that are makers they're
creatives they're tech uh coders writers
architects um
uh sales people uh
it's not unusual at all in business for
us uh in leadership to do the exact
wrong thing and that is because they're
good at their discipline
we think that means they should be a
leader
and leadership is a separate discipline
yes it's a different kind of thing and
you not everyone has to aspire to be in
leadership to make a great income to
have a very fulfilling career
to uh to to to win so the first time i
ever saw this my parents owned a real
estate company when i was growing up and
real estate residential real estate's
the world's worst at it they as soon as
somebody starts selling a bunch they
make themselves
a completely different set of skills to
be sales manager than to be a salesman
you know selling houses are different
than managing people who sell houses it
really is now you need to know some of
the technical things to be able to lead
well and that's in your given space but
um
there are a lot of uh residential real
estate agents that sell houses that make
a lot more than their manager makes yeah
and and so if we just look at
what we love to do so we teach this here
at ramsey solutions talent is what you
do best passion is work you love here's
the reality
leadership is work it is a form it is a
function it is a skill as dave said as
well and so if you don't love
leading people and serving people
there's no shame in that but dave as you
know getting promoted which is stage
five of the seven stages to doing work
you love is getting promoted and many
times as you win people go oh we're
going to put you in management make sure
that you talk to other people who lead
do a little homework and go hey what do
you love most about leading what do you
like least about it and and really soak
in it to make sure that it is something
that you will really want to do because
you know it is one of the most difficult
things in the world to do um because it
is involving humans and we humans
can be great and we humans can be awful
business is great until people get
involved